do i have insecurities yeah and i'm one
to admit it
do i surround myself with things let's
make myself feel better
damn it that's why this show exists so
don't judge just listen
what's up gq i'm lemoine morris and
these
are my essentials
one of my essentials or i should say
many of my essentials
uh are my lebron collection so here we
have
just a few i don't want to take you
upstairs to my room and show you my
closet because i also have
very personal things in there some
things are rather disgusting but these
are
the uh lebron 16 what
is what they're called these are the
diamond turfs and these are the christ
the kings and right now i have on
my laker 17s i had to do it to support
my
nba champions um wishful thinking
i'm not one of those people that's like
obsessive over it though
sure in my closet do i have well over
100 something pairs of lebrons
yes do i wear them often yeah
do i really care do you know what i mean
absolutely but it's not an obsession of
mine
next question
next essential my beats headphones
now a lot of headphones i'm sure have
great sound quality just like these have
however these just feel more accessible
for some reason i don't know like they
go with me everywhere i go
they're easy they're easily connectable
to whatever device you're
you're rocking with and they just look
cool got a gold strip on here before i
go to bed sometimes i'm listening to
music mainly gospel
uh gospel gangster sometimes you gotta
ride out for jesus no
um i'm usually sometimes i'm actually
listening to ocean
sounds to help me sleep if i'm in the
mood to just black out and go to sleep
i'm listening to ocean sounds white
noise
aquatic life you know things like that
[Music]
meow meow energy this stuff here
man has been a lifesaver for me got a
bit of a sweet tooth but it's made with
natural flavors so it's absolutely
fantastic you just squirt a little bit
and some water or an alcoholic beverage
or whatever you want it's got some b
vitamins in it feeling sluggish you can
just toss this in some water and then
you're good to go
and it just tastes absolutely fantastic
a lot of times with these drinks these
little energy things you can
kind of taste whatever chemicals or
whatever the hell they got going on this
thing right here is smooth boom go get
yourself some meal it's fantastic
[Music]
this oh my gosh
you don't want to know what i use this
for i'm lonely nights on the road man
after a game you got to get in the quads
you got to get deep in there
you know during the time of covet people
aren't just handing out massages anymore
so you got to do it yourself get
yourself a personal massager this
hypervolt
by hyper ice oh yeah that's good stuff
so when you come to my house and you
hear this oh
yeah you know what's going down and
that's just the beginning setting
hear that yeah
let's imagine that all up in you
and the cool thing about it is that it
goes deep this definitely
is an essential of mine and it just
looks cool
source naturals wellness formula i
genuinely swear by this stuff
whenever i feel like i'm about to get
like a runny nose or
like a scratchy throat or something like
that i pop six of these
and then it knocks it right out i've
always been on this regimen for sure 100
during the pandemic and during these
weird times we're living in i've gone
through
you know a few more bottles than i'm
used to but that's literally just the
weird paranoia
and i ain't got time i don't i'm just so
busy i don't want anybody sneezing all
over me and if you do sneeze over me
then guess what i'm protected you can't
harm me
my immune system is through the roof you
know what i mean
another one of my essentials it's my
louis duffel bag
this looks cool it's sleek it's sturdy
very sexy
which is not a term i use often because
i am very
very insecure and i do not believe in
myself so when i have this bag it
definitely adds a level of confidence to
myself
does that make sense have you heard
enough about my private life
i can fit a lot of things in this
especially when you're packing the right
way
um depending on your skills you can
what's that what's that lady marie condo
yeah i can recondo this thing and put
like tons of toiletries tons of
underwear tons of socks
maybe one pair of shoes in here i don't
want to like like lebrons have this
bulkiness to it so if you put these in
there you don't really have too much
room for other stuff
like i said before it's sturdy so it's
not going to bust open
another essential this right here may be
the one palmer's cocoa butter i've been
using this ever since i was a kid
i don't know if it's a black thing but
like damn my skin looks good sometimes
it's not just my makeup artist most of
the time it's this cocoa butter smooth
right here it's a dermatologist
recommended
dermatologist named daryl cocoa butter
is just smooth
i you know i've legit never had anything
better than this
and it's so old school like this goes
way way
way way way back so i never leave my
house without having cocoa butter
lathered all over my body
there's two things you need when you
leave the house cocoa butter and jesus
and i got both
this is a recent essential during the
pandemic
i found myself taste testing a lot of
different wines we were sitting in here
in the house all the time going
you know i wonder what this wine tastes
like i wonder what that wine tastes like
so every other day
we would go and like either order more
bottles of wine or go to the grocery
store and get more bottles of wine
and then i stumbled upon kubernetes no
this is not a commercial
i really am obsessed with this stuff
it's to the point where i give it as
gifts now
this is all i drink this is all i order
there's something about it it's
it's aged in in bourbon whiskey barrels
and it's a just a really nice
blend it's very jammy if you will if
you're a somalia out there you know what
i'm talking about
it says dark and jammy oh cause it says
it here on the bottle dark and jammy
with toasty vanilla
notes so do yourself a favor and try
this out
if i'm wrong then i will buy you a
bottle
i love it i'm obsessed with it do i
drink it too much no there's no such
thing
this is a real thing i tried a lot and
then i just stopped buying other ones
and i've tried some of the more natural
things i someone gave me a natural
bottle of wine as a gift
and i gotta be honest with you it tastes
like dog
you know what time it is cooper
i don't wear too much jewelry um but
when i do i get
really gaudy this is made by renvy
r-e-n-v-i
it's a fantastic jeweler that i know and
she's
dope she made me this piece here this
one is one i want to get gaudy
oh my god i love this thing i should
have started with this because it would
make me look a lot cooler again i'm
insecure
boom there's that um and sometimes if i
want to get real stupid
like dumb dumb gotta throw the grill in
and then we're good to go sometimes you
gotta flashy it up sometimes you wanna
go shirtless out there
i'm kidding you don't i gotta get back
in the gym kyle
[Music]
palo santo i recently discovered this
from comet we were hanging out one day a
big group of people and he kept burning
this stuff
he had a lighter and he had a stick in
his hand and he kept
doing that
and then just doing that i was always
like what is that beautiful smell
now common always smells nice you know
he's all eclectic the guy always smells
like earth
and it's always lovely this aroma was
going around when we were hanging out
and i was like what is that he told me
hey man yeah oh this yeah man this palo
santo die like man
you know it was nice man you know just
smell nice and give you positive energy
man
you know you gotta have your own
personal positive energy man
so i was like oh cool common thanks also
raise your voice man you're always
whispering
so i went home ordered a bunch of this
stuff from amazon
and it has been a lifesaver for me i
take it everywhere i go
and then uh whenever i'm you know by
myself or just you know chilling not
doing nothing
light this bad boy up and there you go
can you say a little something words of
affirmation
i will build a better relationship with
my father i will
and then i won't be so insecure i
definitely find it spiritually uplifting
there's something about the the aroma of
it that just puts you in a better
state i'm not sure about the actual
witchcraft elements of it and the voodoo
that people may use with
it i don't know if any of that stuff's
real it just smells nice to me
you know sometimes my deodorant wears
off fast and uh
this right here masks the scent for sure
but be careful
because if you leave it unattended too
you could burn a house down like i
almost did that recently
so just just so you know you burn it
blow it out and then
let that be that
[Music]
so that's it thank you gq for coming to
check out some of my essentials
you ever in the neighborhood come by
i'll give you a nice little rub down
[Music]
[Music]